Prepare for the best
two years of our lives.
I'm sorry.
Right, I'll make some tea.
Thanks for the tea, Joe.
I can offer you a tea,
but you'll have
to make it yourself.
My brother's out.
Would you like some tea?
No, I don't want any tea.
I told you, I was trying
to get us some tea.
Well, fuck the fucking tea!
I'm gonna get some tea.
-Brought you a cup of tea.
-Oh, thank you.
Do you want any tea?
I look quite pretty.
Your hair looks nice today.
Yeah, you're… almost pretty.
Doesn't she look so pretty?
Lovely to meet you.
You're so pretty.
Come in, come in,
we're playing tea parties
with Elsie's dollies.
That's, like, so pretty.
I think
it's a crow.
No, you wouldn't know us.
We're from Moordale,
England.
-You any good at quizzes?
-No.
The American War
of Independence took place
during the reign
of which British king?
Uh, Henry VIII.
-George III.
-Yep.
Fucking tits.
Tits.
They're looking for me.
-Ta-ra, lad.
-See you later, pet.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Sorry, wait. Break?
Sorry, Adam.
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry, Sophie,
I'll turn it down.
-Sorry.
-Oh! Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Sorry, I'm bad with names.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, Ruby.
-Sorry, sorry.
-Sorry.
-I'm sorry.
-I'm so sorry.
-Sorry.
-No, you're…
No, you're not sorry.
-Look at you laughing.
-It's not funny.
-Like a dickhead.
-Shut up.
-Like a fool.
-All right.
-Like an idiot.
-Go clean yourself off.
Yuck. Is that ham?
-We're vegan now, remember?
-Oh right, yeah. I forgot.
My ham.
It's a fancy sandwich.
Cheese and ham.
You know we're
already recording it.
Come on, let's get
the fuck out of here.
Ugh, I do not do fake wool.
This blazer
is itchy as fuck.
At least we look better
in them than everyone else.
-Grey is not my colour.
-Come on, it's not that bad.
I kinda like it.
-Curly Wurly.
-Look, come on, man.
Not my Curly Wurly.
Give me that Curly Wurly
or I will break your face.